could vote on the
[Music]
okay we're back at it this was
unexpected sort of I just found out that
this press conference has been scheduled
presumably presumably to announce the
impeachment of President Donald Trump
after after yesterday's Judiciary
Committee meetings so we are standing by
for what we believe will be that kind of
announcement we I don't know how long it
will go I don't know exactly what will
be said and who will say it but this is
what we know of so far let's take a look
at a couple of news articles about this
the this morning Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi House Judiciary Chairman
Jerry Nadler as well as Adam Schiff are
expected to announce articles of
impeachment against the President of the
United States we will have the
impeachment of a sitting president
according to various reports and sources
articles of impeachment are expected to
be on abuse of power and obstruction of
Congress with a full House vote expected
to occur on Thursday December 12th the
day after tomorrow
this announcement follows weeks of
testimony and hearings in both the House
Intelligence Committee and House
Judiciary Committee so if indeed this is
it if indeed this is the time the
announcement that Democrats will be
doing this it will be time to start
thinking about the possible paths that
this will take I still believe that
unless something significant changes the
odds of actually convicting the
president are almost effectively zero
now we heard from Senator Chris Murphy a
Democrat in the Senate yesterday that he
believes there are a handful of
Republican senators who would consider
convicting Donald Trump on impeachment
the problem with that of course is you
need 67 to do it and even if you get all
45 Democrats
plus the two independents Bernie Sanders
and angus King and five Republicans
you're still at only 50 to 52 and that
is still 15 short of the number that you
need so I don't see the numbers
the advantage to this would be if you
believe you can get it to so damaged
Donald Trump through his impeachment
that you make him easier to defeat in
2020 but it is aside from the political
considerations impeachment is a duty for
Congress and if the facts point that way
Congress must act regardless of
political implications looks like
there's some activity here let's see
what's going on welcome to everybody by
the way I will be taking super chats so
feel free to send them I see one from
Shrek saying dobla dah thank you very
much we will take your reactions via
super chat we see Nancy Pelosi filing in
as well as Jerry Nadler and a number of
other members others Richard Neil one of
the first members of Congress I ever met
over here I hope that's Richard Neil and
we will see presumably Nancy Pelosi will
do the talking there's Adam Schiff as
well
and here is Pelosi good morning everyone
on the solemn day I'm I recall that the
first order of business for members of
Congress is the solemn act to take an
oath to protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States with
great respect and gratitude that I thank
the chairs of the committees the six
committees who have been working to help
us honor our oath of office I also want
to thank the staff of those committees
and the committee members for all of
their work over this period of time to
help us protect and defend I want to
thank the chairman of the Judiciary
Committee mr. Nadler chair of the
Intelligence Committee mr. Schiff a
chair of the Ways and Means it's the
chair of the Foreign Affairs Committee
eliot Engel of New York the chair of the
Financial Services Committee Maxine
Waters of California the chair of the
Committee on Government Reform and
oversight congresswoman carolyn Maloney
I also want to acknowledge the important
work that was done by our dear and
departed may rest in peace Elijah
Cummings as chair of the Community
Oversight Committee now pleased to yield
to the distinguished chair of the
Judiciary Committee mr. Navin now we
will hear from Nadler presumably about
what we heard yesterday in the hearing
about 10 hours thank you madam Speaker
over the last several months the
investigative committees of the house
have been engaged in an impeachment
inquiry into President Donald Trump's
efforts to solicit foreign interference
in the 2020 elections efforts that
compromised our national security and
threatened the integrity of our
elections throughout this inquiry he has
attempted to conceal the evidence from
Congress and from the American people
our president holds the ultimate public
trust when he betrays
that trust and puts himself before
country he in dangers the Constitution
he endangered our democracy and he
endangered our national security the
framers of the Constitution prescribed a
clear remedy for presidents who so
violate their oath of office that is the
power of impeachment today in service to
our duty to the Constitution and to our
country the House Committee on the
judiciary is introducing two articles of
impeachment charging the President of
the United States Donald J Trump with
committing high crimes and misdemeanors
the first article is for abuse of power
it is an impeachable offense for the
President to exercise the powers of his
public office to obtain an improper
personal benefit while ignoring or
injuring the national interest that is
exactly what President Trump did when he
solicited and pressured Ukraine to
interfere in our 2020 presidential
election thus damaging our national
security undermining the integrity of
the next election and violating his oath
to the American people these actions
moreover are consistent with president
Trump's previous invitations of foreign
interference in our 2016 presidential
election and when he was caught when the
House investigated and opened an
impeachment inquiry president Trump
engaged in unprecedented categorical and
indiscriminate defiance of the
impeachment inquiry this gives rise to
the second article of impeachment for
obstruction of Congress here too we see
a familiar pattern in president Trump's
misconduct a president who declares
himself above accountability above the
American people and above Congress's
power of impeachment which is meant to
protect
against threats to our democratic
institutions is the president who sees
himself as above the law we must be
clear no one not even the president is
above the law I want to recognize the
great contributions of the investigative
chairs particularly Intelligence
Committee Chairman Adam Schiff Foreign
Affairs Chairman eliot engel Committee
on Oversight and reform former chairman
the late Elijah Cummings and its new
chairwoman carolyn Maloney Financial
Services chairwoman Maxine Waters and
Ways and Means chairman Richard Neal who
helped lay the foundation for the
articles we are introducing today I also
want to thank my Judiciary Committee
colleagues who were critical in our work
to hold the president accountable and
then the drafting of these articles
later this week the Judiciary Committee
will meet to consider these articles of
impeachment and to make a recommendation
to the full House of Representatives we
do not take this action lightly but we
have taken an oath to defend the
Constitution and unlike President Trump
we understand that our duty first and
foremost is to protect the Constitution
and to protect the interests of the
American people that is why we must take
this solemn step today elections are the
cornerstone of democracy and are
foundational to the rule of law but the
integrity of our next election is at
risk from a president who has already
sought foreign interference in the 2016
and 2020 elections and who consistently
puts himself above country that is why
we must act now I want to turn now to
chairmanship we'll explain the evidence
that supports these articles and the
need for us to act with such urgency
today Thank You mr. chairman thank you
madam Speaker and to my colleagues good
morning the framers of the Constitution
recognized that some day a president
might come to office who would abuse
that
betray the public trust and undermine
national security to secure foreign help
in his reelection and who would seek to
abrogate the power of Congress to hold
him accountable they recognize this
danger and they prescribed a remedy and
that remedy is impeachment it is an
extraordinary remedy and one that I've
been reluctant to recommend until the
actions of President Trump gave Congress
no alternative we stand here today
because the president's continuing abuse
of his power has left us no choice to do
nothing would make ourselves complicit
in the president's abuse of his high
office the public trust and our national
security
the president's misconduct is as simple
and as terrible as this president Trump
solicited a foreign nation
Ukraine to publicly announce
investigations into his opponent and a
baseless conspiracy theory promoted by
Russia to help his reelection campaign
President Trump abused the power of his
office by conditioning two official acts
to get Ukraine to help his reelection
the release of hundreds of millions of
dollars in military aid that nation
desperately needed and a White House
meeting with an ally trying to fend off
Russian aggression in so doing he
undermined our national security and
jeopardized the integrity of our next
election and he does so still the
evidence of the president's misconduct
is overwhelming and uncontested and how
could it not be when the president's own
words on July 25th I would like you to
do us a favor though lay so bare his
intentions his willingness to sacrifice
the national security for his own
personal interests and when the
president got caught he committed his
second impeachable Act obstruction of
Congress of the very ability to make
sure that no one is above the law not
even the President of the United States
the evidence is every bit as strong that
President Trump has obstructed
Congress fully without precedent and
without basis in law if allowed to stand
it would decimate Congress's ability to
conduct oversight of this president or
any other in the future leaving this
president and those who follow to be
free to be as corrupt malfeasant or
incompetent as they would like with no
prospect of discovery or accountability
now some would argue why don't you just
wait why don't you just wait until you
get these witnesses the White House
refuses to produce why don't you just
wait until you get the documents the
White House refuses to turn over and
people should understand what that
argument really means it has taken us
eight months to get a lower court ruling
that dawn McGann has no absolute right
to defy Congress eight months for one
court decision if it takes us another
eight months to get a second court or
maybe a Supreme Court decision people
need to understand that is not the end
of the process it comes back to us and
we ask questions because he no longer
has absolute immunity and then he claims
something else that his answers are
privileged and we have to go to back to
court for another eight or sixteen
months the argument why don't you just
wait amounts to this why don't you just
let him cheat in one more election why
not let him cheat just one more time why
not let him have foreign help just one
more time that is what that argument
amounts to the president's misconduct
goes to the heart of whether we can
conduct a free and fair election in 2020
it is bad enough for a candidate to
invite for interference in our political
process but it is far more corrosive for
a president to do so and to abuse his
power to make it so despite everything
we have uncovered the president's
misconduct continues to this day
unapologetically and right now as we saw
when he stood on the
House lawn and he was asked what did you
want in that July 25th call and he said
the answer was a simple one and not just
a simple one on July 25th but a simple
one today and that is he still wants
Ukraine to interfere in our election to
help his campaign even this the
president's lawyer was back in Ukraine
seeking to revive the same debunked
conspiracy theory promoted at the
president's behest which gets to the
final and most pernicious of the
arguments that we have heard in the
president's defense that the president
can do whatever he wants under Article
two including get foreigners involved in
our elections and we should just to
quote the president's chief of staff get
over it
Ben Franklin said we have a republic if
we can keep it the president and his men
say you can't keep it and Americans
should just get over it
Americans don't get to decide American
elections anymore
not by themselves not without foreign
help for the members of Congress this is
not a question of fact because the facts
are not seriously contested it is rather
a question of duty
the president's oath of office appears
to mean very little to him but the
articles put forward today will give us
a chance to show that we will defend the
Constitution and that our oath means
something to us I thank you mr. chairman
laying out the case in the least
political terms possible which i think
is the right way to do it
of course it won't convince the trumpet
but it's right to say this is merely
what the facts say we must do it looks
like that is it so we will have time to
take questions here whoa okay so that
seems to have gone away all right let's
get away from that let's see I wanted to
get to there's so much to discuss here
truly and I want to hear your questions
about it let me see if I can get the
c-span feedback up
but I cannot so Democrats announcing the
impeachment whoa things going crazy here
just things getting a little hectic this
was planned very very last-minute things
getting a little hectic here I'm glad to
take from folks via super chat about
what is going on but this is the
beginning of what is going to be a very
very long thing I don't know how else to
say it but this is only the beginning
some reports saying that there could be
a vote in the house as soon as December
12 others saying no that's when
Democrats are merely going to start
meeting going to start meeting in order
to talk about all of this let's see here
I think we did have see if we can get
the video back although it seems to have
stopped
hmm in any case I will take I will take
questions from folks let's see CNN has
it everything falling apart here very
very last minute stream and for that I
apologize this even surprised me but we
are here we are here that is for sure
although everything else seems to be
going wrong and I don't know why that is
white screen white screen of death yes
some kind of a some some kind of a
problem happening although we don't know
exactly what Donald Trump of course
tweeting as well any number of times and
I expect that he will be tweeting more
Trump's only tweet so far to impeach a
president who has proven through results
including producing perhaps the
strongest economy in our country's
history to have one of the most
successful presidencies ever and most
importantly who has done nothing wrong
is sheer political madness well again
Adam Schiff making the case that this is
not about politics this is just about
what happened and do the facts say that
it is time to impeach David Mazur says
who was behind Schiff in to his left is
that Maloney I'm not I'm not sure who
that was a drew gue says for everyone's
screaming hearsay a hearsay statement
may be allowed if it describes her
explains an
Venter conditioned and was made during
the event or immediately after it yeah
this this idea of hearsay that people
are throwing around is very much
misunderstood Gord Orvis says have a
beer to celebrate John McKinney says
people forget Bill Clinton's impeachment
in 1999 did not help him Al Gore lost
the 2000 election because of it
Morton Hermanson says the bad thing
about removing Trump is that we'll all
have to get a Netflix subscription a
Kent it'll be a boon for Netflix full
disclosure I'm a Netflix shareholder so
I guess I shouldn't complain about that
mark says do you think any Republican
senators will impeach you know Chris
Murphy says he knows of five Republican
senators who might vote to convict I am
skeptical of that I am very very
skeptical of that I don't know that I
see that as hugely likely he claims it's
possible but Mathilda Nordahl says hi
from a Swede in Switzerland Thank You
Mathilda I appreciate the support the
hearing has ended four people just
joining us the hearing has ended but we
are taking questions via super chat and
talking about the implications remember
that the best way the best way to
support what have been 100% coverage
livestreams of everything impeachment
related now 60 hours almost of streams
is to get a membership at david
pakman.com or actually better said at
join pakman.com will take you straight
there
a one person who just did that is indeed
matilda Nordau thank you matilda who
just sent a super chat I very much
appreciate that takes just a minute and
it supports all of these streams that
have been relentlessly continuing here
so as Adam Schiff and Jerry Nadler laid
out two articles of impeachment will
charge Donald Trump the first one is for
abuse of power the idea there that the
president exercised his powers as a
public office holder to obtain an
improper personal benefit while ignoring
or injuring the national interest that
is what Trump Democrats assert did by
holding conditionally hundreds of
millions of dollars in military
and the White House meeting with
president zalenski in exchange for these
public announcements of investigations
into Joe Biden then when impeachment the
when the impeachment inquiry started
Donald Trump obstructed Congress this is
the second count this is the second
count that they say Donald Trump
committed and that that is essentially
the president declaring himself above
accountability and that for that he will
also be impeached that is what has taken
place so far I am assuming Donald Trump
will soon be tweeting the the his last
tweet was from an hour ago before the
start of the impeachment hearings and I
would assume at some point there will be
breathtaking insanity on Donald Trump's
Twitter account the adolescent parent
asking hello from Dallas do you think
Donald Trump will testify no we'll
Ukrainian representatives unsure can
they I believe that they could I believe
that they could but I don't know
kupah j-- says good morning David I just
got here catch me up yeah well the
Donald Trump is being impeached on two
counts he is being impeached on one
count of abuse of power and one count of
obstruction of Congress and we are still
waiting to find out more about the
schedule initially there was a report
that there would be a full House vote
two days from now on Thursday December
12th we don't know if there will be
further public hearings about this
before that vote takes place or whether
the Judiciary Committee will make the
case privately then we would be talking
about a Senate trial this is this is
just the beginning this is absolutely
just the beginning and this is going to
be a long one a thanks to John Ringo
John ring